[Background wind noise]
MALE >> So let's answer the question if the
environment is going to lose
out to the economy in 2009. My answer is very
simple. It's a clear
"yes." The environment has always lost to
the economy and 2009-it's not
going to be an exception.
FEMALE >> First of all we must recognize that
the environment is a part
of our global economy and should not be considered
as a separate entity.
MALE 2 >> This is a bit of a strange question
because the economy is
just the amount of trading going on. If you
look at GDP, that's the
product of everything bought and sold. Lots
of trading, GDP goes up,
less trading, GDP goes down. So there never
really was a clash between
the environment and the economy. It just depends
on what's being traded.
Trade in environmentally friendly economic
goods, boost economic growth.
Also, environmental issues will still be around
in ten years but the
recession won't be. The long term profits
are in environmental jobs and
the smart business people will see that.
MALE 3 >> There is hope, but for that hope
we've got to correct critical
imbalance that we've got in our economies
and that we've had long before
the credit crunch. It's been getting worse
over time and now more than
ever it's so critical to correct it.
MALE 4 >> If you're looking the problem straight
in the eye, it's not
cars or light bulbs, furnaces or air conditioners,
it's not coal miners,
oil executives or the tar sands. The main
problem is what I'm doing right
now [zoom to gasoline hose nozzle in vehicle],
freely and lawfully. I'm
using fossil fuels for energy.
MALE 5 AT CHALKBOARD >> So there you have
it. When you take the world
economic forum and you add in healthy ecology
and you take away the flow
of oil and coal, what you're left with is
a healthy environment and a
healthy economy. And I think the answer to
this equation is what all
world economists need to include if they're
going to make sure that they
have a healthy economy and a healthy environment
in 2009.
They need to include youth in their discussions
and furthermore, they
need to support hydrogen based technologies
and help us build the
hydrogen economy.
MALE 6 >> Time is obviously not on our side.
We need to wake up and
smell the methane.
[Background music] MALE 7 >> The time to act
is now for socially
responsible investments that can create green
cities, clean industries
and sustainable agrable forest based economies.
We can plant the seeds
of hope for a sustainable future for us all.